y
tiempo de hablar de economía de france
24 y ahora vamos a hablar del gigante de
la inmobiliaria china evergrande y de su
posibilidad de quiebra pero todavía
muchos nos preguntamos qué significa
evergrande y cuál es su relevancia y
precisamente para hablar de eso está con
nosotros nuestro periodista experto en
economía jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
gracias a mar clara bueno a nivel
general evergrande es el segundo
desarrollador inmobiliario más grande de
china este gigante asiático es parte de
global 500 lo que la convierte en una de
las empresas más grandes del mundo
actualmente emplea a unas doscientas mil
personas y genera de forma indirecta
3.8 millones de puestos de trabajo
la empresa es conocida por sus más de
mil proyectos inmobiliarios
pero sus inversiones más claras están en
casi todos los sectores económicos de
china e incluso en el deporte en los
últimos años la deuda de efrén se
disparó a medida que pedía préstamos
para financiar sus actividades uso el
apalancamiento al límite y creó una
deuda de 300 mil millones en pasivos
para darte unidad esto es como el
producto interno bruto de un país como
chile fue allí cuando el mundo comenzó a
escuchar el nombre de herrera
consultamos sobre el impacto de esta
posible quiebra en los mercados
mundiales con alejandro godoy él es
especialista en estudios asiáticos y
esto nos dijo muy interesante porque nos
damos cuenta que aunque haya pasado ya
un poco más de 13 años desde esa crisis
de lehman brothers y todo lo que
conlleva una caída mundial muy fuerte
estos temores de colapso de esta empresa
se podrían ver reflejados en un contagio
financiero y frenar el crecimiento de la
economía china y por ahí desde hace
mucho tiempo hablamos cuando china
estornuda
le da gripa en términos financieros de
igual manera también nos está diciendo
que a raíz de la pandemia la gente ha
estado buscando refugiar sus inversiones
más en el tema inmobiliario y que no
siempre lo que promete el sector
inmobiliario se puede cumplir sin
embargo también frente a la madurez que
se está viendo en el mercado
inmobiliario de china también estas
empresas se están moviendo a otros
mercados como el continente africano
pues eso sí puede impactar en el
crecimiento del único país que fue
positivo el año anterior que por la
pandemia de la coidh 19 como vimos una
caída mundial bastante fuerte jorge y
más allá de evergrande cuál es la
situación del sector inmobiliario en
china y cómo afecta todo esto américa
latina' una buena pregunta para darnos
una idea nos remitimos a un estudio
sobre la vivienda en china que realizó
la universidad de albany y afirman que
allí el 90% de los ciudadanos son
propietarios de sus casas esta es una de
las tasas más altas del mundo si lo
comparamos en con eeuu por ejemplo el 65
3% los ciudadanos son dueños de sus
casas y en alemania
el 51,1 por ciento pero detrás de este
porcentaje de la expansión del sector
inmobiliario ha estado marcado por una
burbuja hay muchas ciudades fantasmas
infraestructura en el olvido y el modelo
de construcción ha sido bastante
agresivo pero como podría impactar esta
quiebra en américa latina' nos responde
nuestro invitado alejandro jdd
bien sabemos que las economías
latinoamericanas son economías que van
al ritmo de las materias primas y lo que
llamamos nosotros mundialmente
commodities sobre todo hay un grupo de
economías latinoamericanas que podrían
estar más en riesgo que otras en este
concepto vemos a perú chile y brasil
porque porque son las que más le venden
material de construcción a esta empresa
ya muchas de china con el tema del
hierro con el tema del cobre que son
fundamentales también colombia y
venezuela se verían bastante afectadas
en el sentido que son economías que
viven prácticamente del tema del
petróleo
jorge cuál es el papel del gobierno
chino
bueno varias firmas ya disminuyeron las
expectativas de crecimiento en china
hasta el 86 por ciento para 2021 pero
tras el negativo de los números
económicos podría crearse un malestar
social por la cantidad de viviendas que
quedarían incompletas escuchemos que que
hay de la intervención o la posible
intervención de beijing en esta crisis
y aunque el partido comunista no está
apoyando como como lo vimos en los eeuu
la recuperación y lanzar un salvavidas a
la empresa en los próximos meses lo que
sí está haciendo es que otras empresas
estatales como que vayan comprando en
algunas zonas específicas como wang yu
la deuda de la compañía para no entrar
en este impago y lo que busca al mediano
plazo es decir dentro de los próximos
seis meses a un año es desmontar la
compañía y entregarle esos proyectos
inmobiliarios a otras para que puedan
terminarlo y de esa manera no no las
personas puedan en este sentido no
ocupar sus unidades habitacionales
graciasjorge y continúen con más el
france24
i
[Música]